welcome back to New rockstars now that
nemour is officially in the MCU we begin
to wonder if he's met any of the other
numerous powered individuals kicking
around on this planet and that includes
a group of space robots who have a lot
of family issues oh my gosh
yeah we can really get into this but you
guys this is the big question the show
that asks and answers the biggest
questions floating around in the nerd
sphere and a few of the small ones while
we're at it you guys I'm Jessica Clemons
and join with me today is my best friend
in the world oh my God best friend in
the universe oh my gosh the love of my
life whoa solid back Brandenburg oh my
gosh thank you Jessica it's so good to
be back with you uh and be back on the
official big question now that our
fantasy stuff is done uh and as you
folks at home have probably already
noticed we've made some changes here on
big question got ourselves a new little
set we're live and in person we're
standing we're standing don't tell
anyone we're standing it's great for our
calves yeah my my knees are feeling it
oh yeah uh but most of all this is gonna
be the same big question you've always
loved we're gonna a great time but one
thing we changed about the show is that
we love answering the questions you
folks at home send in so we want to do
more of that so this new format will
give us the opportunity to do just that
but it wouldn't be a big question
without a big question to kick us off
right Jessica so let's get into it our
big question for today so of all the big
Revelations we got in the recently
released black panther wakanda forever
one of the biggest was learning that the
mutant leader of talocon AKA no more has
been alive for quite some time right
he's been around for a few hundred years
uh so knowing that no more has been
hanging out in the ocean for hundreds of
years it makes us wonder who else in the
MCU he might have run into It All Leads
us to this week's big question did the
eternals know about no more
um Jessica you remember the eternals
right you record that film you don't
recall it at all oh I don't know what
they are uh well they're you know
they're the celestial built Immortal
robotic doulas that were hanging around
on Earth for thousands of years you know
they thought they were here to help
Humanity evolve and keep but safe from
the deviants but they eventually learned
that their true purpose was to help
cultivate our sweet sweet energy to help
that little baby Celestial inside the
earth gestate and eventually hatch
killing all of us thank you eternals I
feel like Steven Universe did the same
thing oh okay save it save a pocket that
one can't wait for that big question all
right right so anyways the eternals they
traveled the globe and they met
burgeoning societies and cultures
everywhere but did these space droids
ever run into no more and then Tallow
Canal huh let's look at the evidence and
see if we can figure that out just a
second I shouldn't have put ice in this
cup and I'm sorry but let's look at this
evidence it's delicious ice okay the
first piece of evidence we have that the
two parties could have crossed paths is
laid out pretty well in the films for
both eternals and black panther wakanda
forever and that of course is location
location what is it location location
location
I hear I don't know the song location
location
location
okay well we know that the eternals were
hanging out with the Aztecs and
technocticlon in the 16th century okay
uh in the eternals film it showed us
that they were there when the Spanish
attacked the Aztec capital in 1521.
that's uh where the group decided to
split up for a little while and go
exploring on their own remember Druid
was like why are we letting them do this
and Ajax was like we have to let them do
this and it's like guys you probably
should have stopped the Spanish horrible
Ajax impression that was that was a
terrible was it terrible uh I think it
sounded just like her uh so that's
happening in 1521 okay in technoctagon
now Namor is born in 1571 right 50 years
later in Yucatan Mexico which is like
kind of on the peninsula of of Mexico
down in the Yucatan Peninsula you may
have heard of that uh and technoctagon
is located in what is now known as
Mexico City which is more Central in the
country of Mexico uh our lovely editors
will give you a map because I'm not
explaining it well show some so some
pamphlets yeah yeah so so a little
dotted line beautiful so these two these
two locations we don't know exactly
where Nemours uh tribe was in the
Yucatan uh but it was obviously on the
coast because they were able to dive
right into the water but as the crow
flies they're about 600 miles apart from
each other uh so so these two events
happen about 600 miles apart about 50
years apart now that that seems like a a
big gap wait what what Crow a crow you
never heard the term as the crow flies
no oh I thought there was a crow in the
movie I was like there's no crow in the
movie no I've never heard that saying in
my life oh well I'm an old man you are
because if you were to look at a map
right if you were to drive from
technology is that saying that's close
yeah because like if you were to drive
over land from technoctagon to the
Yucatan it's like a much longer distance
because they're kind of uh on opposite
ends of a horseshoe right but if you
just fly like directly you don't have to
take roads it's only like 600 I hate
that saying
so these two events happen like 50 years
apart 600 miles apart right but for
beings that are living hundreds of years
that's kind of close yeah it's very
close now Neymar is born a mutant and
his power manifested a relatively young
age different from what we know from
mutants in the comics right usually
happens at puberty but he was already
showing Powers at a very young age able
to breathe uh air unlike the rest of his
telekinil Brethren and we know that uh
druig kind of stuck around the area
right uh when when technocticon
falls apart and the eternals are like
we're splitting we're gonna go our own
ways we've been together for too long we
need to just go like live and do our
thing druick stays around the area he
goes to like the Peruvian Amazon uh and
he forms a settlement with people they
live in isolation on the shores of Lake
junin okay now this what we know about
like these bodies of water is that like
no more has a way of like getting into
them right he's able to like swim up the
river to wakanda to that Lake in wakanda
so I would assume that there's probably
a way that he can get into these Lakes
if this lake is fed by a river somehow
right he could be able to get there and
like check out drewig's little sediment
yeah you know what I mean the thing is
I'm sure okay so long story short in my
opinion I'm sure that Drake was like Hey
I can help you and he was like don't
come near my people do not come near my
people don't even think about it right
and they're probably like because they
were their whole thing was like oh we're
fixing we're helping we're teaching
people how to do things we're advancing
them and it's like animals like we'll be
fine just leave us alone and I think
they're like okay we abide by what he
said he said to leave them alone and not
to come in their water so we're not
gonna do that remember no More's first
interaction with people above the the
water line is seeing you know uh the
slavery happening and like uh you know
the persecution of people and he's like
oh this is how everything is above the
water line so even if druid's like no we
had a peaceful settlement here he's
probably like [ __ ] also to be fair
in the journals they're spoiler I saw
eternals I was joking at the beginning
also in eternals my favorite part and I
can't remember uh Tyree Henry what what
he recognized that he just gave weapons
to start a war I think essentially is
like seeing that like the slavery that
was happening was probably like did we
do something to start this did we help
them and then stop it they didn't stop
it well I mean what you gonna do you
can't go back and try to fix it you're
gonna make it worse right they cannot
travel through time and if things
they're supposed to like kind of be
hands-offs and if it doesn't involve
deviants do you think it was before
that's at that time that they were
basically like we were told not to
meddle anymore and that was one of those
times where we were told not to yeah
well their whole thing was like if it
doesn't involve deviance if this is just
humans being humans we have to let them
do it to find a deviant because those
were Divas
oh my gosh is this how you get your sick
kicks oh my goodness so Drake's hanging
out in the Peruvian Amazon he's starting
his little people uh and he's there for
a long time although we assume all the
way up until modern day as we saw in the
movie so at some point he's probably
hearing stories about this like child
right who eventually grows into a man uh
and he's probably hearing about it and I
love the idea that druig and Neymar have
an interaction because druid's not
talking with the other uh eternals he's
talking with uh Makari right they're
still on speaking terms so Makari might
know about no more and Druid might know
about no more and I I love the idea that
Drake knows about it he's not going to
tell the other yeah that's true right
I mean stupid stupid idea what if
they're genuinely because he's known as
the feather servant God he's like oh
it's just another one of us oh that oh
that's a good point because he just
doesn't care to like acknowledge or be
involved with them but I I assume they
know how many there are they were like
we were the only ones yeah I I don't
assume that they threw extras in there
that they just don't care about or know
about well maybe they do because we do
have Harry Styles eventually coming in
so it's like there are more there are
others well and we know that the
eternals are aware of like avatars right
I think I think they're aware of like
the Black Panther Avatar wait what wait
what you know because you mean them
being robots or you mean people like
God's going through them yes the God's
going through like they know there's a
black panther who's taken at some point
in history they know there's a black
panther there's a heart-shaped derp
they're probably very aware of wakanda
but they know it wants to say secret so
they keep it secret right
I think that Druid knows about no more
they meet at some point and Drew is like
you cool and no More's like you cool and
they're like we're good together because
I think druig and no more are very
similar oh no absolutely right they want
to keep their people safe they want to
help well Drake wanted to protect
everybody right where no more is like
I'm only trying to protect my people
right but druig is just protecting his
people at some point yeah yeah he did
want to protect everybody Ajax said no
you can't do that and he's like all
right fine I'll just protect these these
couple hundred people
that's bad it's terrible uh it's
terrible at all but so yeah I I would
believe that drug is aware of it he's in
the area he's probably getting here
hearing stories about this feather
serpent God looks into it meets the more
it's all it's all the other serpent Gods
you say it's only got feathers on his
ankles on his ankle not his whole body
and I thought it was a full snake you're
a fraud a snake with wings what's more
scary that would be scary I mean we saw
that in Shang Chi right like that was
basically a snake with wings that is a
great protective but I'm imagining like
a gardener snake that's just massive
that would be scary why did it have to
be snakes with wings it's also important
to note that the reason no More's mother
was forced to take that herb and her
people were taking the herb that they
discovered right was because of a
smallpox outbreak now the Spanish first
arrived in Mexico in 1519 and by 1521
they were already like destroying
Technic line they're bringing the
smallpox in right so if later on like
years later if no more you know he's
trying to avenge his mother in some way
he's like I wonder where this smallpox
came from that killed my that wiped out
my people and pushed us into the water
right he he might trace it all the way
back to technoctagon and kind of find
out what happened there and if he's
aware of druig and he's aware of like
the eternals he would probably be pretty
pissed that the eternals did nothing to
stop this from happening whether he's
right or not I bet he would be be angry
well my thing is oh okay so I think you
can jump to that conclusion without even
him having to travel to find smallpox I
think he witnessed it and was like oh
this is something I don't know but
easily killed off an entire civilization
so maybe I shouldn't go touching people
and then bringing it back to my freaking
town but I do think there's a jump that
can be made and even just drew again him
Druid Druid Druid drigg meeting and I
always call him Barry kogan
but uh those two meeting and him being
like
what are you doing what are you you guys
were supposed to do stuff right you're
not doing stuff so I think you can just
jump to that conclusion without even I I
he probably hates because even even
Drake doesn't really know you know none
of the eternals know why they're there
they're told they're there to protect
the humanity humanity and save it from
the deviance right and if he says that
to no more no more is probably like well
why aren't you doing more right you guys
have power you're not using it kind of
what he accuses like wakanda of doing in
a way he he's more mad at them for like
exposing themselves but he's also mad
because like they have power and they
should be protecting their people and
they're not doing that and now they're
putting everyone at risk so I could see
no more being very angry about this
situation absolutely and knowing that
like no more is able to keep tabs on
what's going on in the world without the
world finding out about him he's
probably since he's living for a long
time too he's noticing like hey I've
seen these people around before yeah or
like I I'm hearing stories about these
people I'm hearing stories about like
Athena uh and Hermes and stuff like
these gods and they exist and I know
they exist what also we're assuming that
um Barry kogan told him I feel like I
could see a world I bet barricade he
doesn't yeah drug tells him everything I
I think there's a world where he doesn't
he doesn't he's just like no like
because I think when I say no I mean
like he's just like no I don't want to
talk about it because he's like I know a
lot of the behind the scenes I know that
there's a d Vance I know there's more
people like us why am I going to tell
this mutant that is flying at me from
the water who's clearly not a deviant
right uh I could see him questioning him
but I think also Barry kogan which he
made it clear he's very smart and
eternals yeah so I think he's probably
like
I'm going to stick to my thing you stick
to yours because like last time I tried
to involve everyone everybody died and
everyone they didn't want to fight with
me anymore do you think you tried to
mind control no more and was unable to
unable to oh probably well the thing is
we don't know what wasn't his powers was
so long ago he was forcing people I
thought people voluntarily joined no no
he just kind of like does it and then I
think I think at some point he doesn't
have to control their minds anymore
because they're living in peace in the
jungle but he can just do it when he
wants to do it I think I won't go home I
want to go home I want to use a real
toilet mama papa I want to use a [ __ ]
I want toast like we have toast here oh
my God no but you have to like start a
fire yeah I want to just plug a toaster
in I have a bread maker
okay well let's talk about the eternal's
ability to visit talocon okay in theory
if they were able to locate this
underwater city they would be able to
visit it because we know we see that
Icarus is able to survive the vacuum of
space So in theory none of these
eternals need to breathe right because
when he's flying to the sun he's still
like alive he's not dead out there in
the vacuum of space and we see you know
like Cersei get pulled into space by a
Celestial but I don't know if celestials
are able to like generate oxygen around
them but these robots don't need oxygen
and assuming that Icarus is able to
survive the lack of pressure in space he
probably could survive the strong
pressures of being underwater he's
basically Superman yeah so any of the
eternals would be able to go down to
Tech the thing is I don't know if it's
everyone I think it is if they all have
that ability I think well that's also
the thing is like they're they're
creative they all have like the same
bass Powers Yeah
yeah but I think yeah I think that's the
thing though is like I don't think
fastos could the fastest that we have
he's not maybe better durable enough
it's not really even durable I think
it's just that like it is just Icarus
that's what made Icarus the leader
that's what made Icarus the all like the
best one the best one is because he
physically could do all these things
where I'm like and I know like in the
comics it's like well the actual
strongest one is like Cersei because she
can do anything to anything but it's
like I don't think she has the
capabilities of doing those things that
he could do well like that physically
does that make sense I hope that makes
sense I think I think there's a reason
they've made a hierarchy in themselves
well and if fastos knew they were down
there he could make a device yeah and
that's maybe he could make a submarine
if that's the thing they could all get
down there in this different ways maybe
like I can make a ship well we were
saying we were talking about the idea
that like in their ship right they have
this big ship there must be something in
there that they're able to track
clusters of Humanity on earth right
because I know where to be to find these
cultures and now in theory Makari could
just run around the globe and be like I
found some people here here and here but
I bet they have something on their ship
that's like you need to go over here now
or you need to come check out this life
they probably have to create it right
and they don't have them because they're
not just like one that can be aimlessly
wandering around trying to find like
Babylonians they kind of are I think I
know they don't have fast
so it's like and I feel like he'd be the
one like crazy I'm talking about early
on they have facts oh oh wait wait
you're saying the ship that they showed
up on earlier yes yes yes would still
have the technology when they first
arrived on Earth yes
no no also again don't want to do this
in Steven Universe the thing that's in
the middle of the earth is called the
cluster and it's going to explode and
take over Earth and that's how they're
brought is this like what I'm asking is
this like uh something that is in books
do I not know about is this like
whatever I just it's like the same thing
with like Icarus we all know the tall
tale of Icarus so I'm like is there a
tall tale about something growing in the
middle of Earth well there's always I
mean there's tons of Mythology about
like what's inside the earth uh and
Jules Verne famously wrote Journey to
the Center of the Earth the idea that
there's a hollow Earth and there's like
a whole other Universe in there like a
whole other world so yeah a mythology is
full of the ideas of what's inside of
the Earth so I think the idea of like
you know a Celestial seed being in there
it just fits in it's just one of the
many things let me go crazy what's in
that Earth what's in that Earth but I
think I would think that the eternals
have some way of finding clusters of
humanity early on now they do split up
before Nemours born and before talocon
gets like formed I think eventually if
they let's say they have this device
they could be like we should check out
we're getting this weird reading in the
middle of the ocean down deep we should
probably send someone down there to
check it out and I think they do at some
point I bet they were like let's go see
what's down there just to make sure or
or they might have early on being like
we should we need to like check the
oceans too because there could be life
down there I think they stopped doing
their jobs along like immediately I mean
and when I say immediately to them could
be like 100 years but I think they
stopped their jobs as soon as they
notice the people on Earth are more are
like kind of running the machines
running we can kind of step back that
and I well yeah because there's a sole
job
they think all the deviants are gone
yeah exactly so I think which is not to
immediately blow up this entire big
question but I think a lot of their job
was like even if there are people
underwater and in the water as long as
there's no deviants there's no deviants
but also they're doing fine yeah they
also have a protector that's the thing
they might have they might have the
people on Earth that were in villages
that didn't have anything they're like
oh we can help these people these people
are freaking fine right they help which
makes me wonder if the deviants ever
interacted with the talo canal I'm sure
Neymar would have wiped them out either
I think if Eternal should come out
they'll get into the deviants a lot more
than what we wanted like from the comics
and I think there's a lot of deviants
that aren't bad that are pre probably
people that are just normal looking
people in the water they're just trying
to live I mean the first shot we have of
a deviant in Eternal is coming out of
the water yeah so there could be some
down there and you know when the
eternals are like we killed them all
there could still be some in the water
they didn't know about that no more is
busy killing and he just thinks oh this
is just another weird sea creature I
gotta kill we uh again like in the
comics they do the the deviants live
underwater you have to go under though
in the water deep deep down where they
have a little civilization so it's like
yeah there's another world there that's
not which could be one of the local
cities one of the tolocan Cities yeah
could be a city of deviance because the
thing is I really like the idea when
they were like yeah we can they ride
whales so it's like maybe they do have
the spiritual level with them that it's
like anything in the water we befriend
yeah we don't prefer for some reason
I think they're like these are just
they're eating fish we don't really they
don't mess with us we don't mess with
them because a lot of eternals is them
starting [ __ ] with the deviants where I
was like you guys are killing the
deviants in the comics you're you're on
the money because like the history of
Atlantis and the comics involves the
Deviant yeah and the celestials and the
eternals and there's another sunken city
called lemuria which is full of deviance
but again the comics version of deviants
oh humanoid they're not weird monsters
didn't we already see lamura in the MCU
the ship was named the Lemurian star in
uh Captain America the Winter Soldier
that was our only reference to lamaria
okay either way unless I they actually
they might have mentioned that on Agents
of Shield they might have thought in
Loki we saw it but maybe that we didn't
see it nah we didn't see lemurray yeah
they haven't established lemuria in the
morning
there was a ship called the Lemurian
star and I think they maybe reference it
in Agents of Shield
but it does seem like
um the more has different cities
underwater at different places I would
love one of the Cities being just like
where the deviants are and it's ruled by
like a deviant that is generically
looking human I like that just like a
generic looking human but they're
technically bred as a deviant I like
that well let's talk about something
from the ending of eternals Jessica
which is what Tiamat who
who turned to stone we saw him emerge
from him or her I don't I don't know too
much gender it we saw them emerge from
the earth and they get turned into stone
and be stuck there in the water and no
one will talk about it in the MCU
someone talk about it it was a headline
it was a headline actually She-Hulk Dr
Maddie but after we saw eternals a lot
of us thought like oh this is gonna this
is why Neymar shows up right he's like
what the hell's going on in my ocean you
know we thought that would be the
impetus but it never gets brought up and
we're kind of forever I mean no more
must have been like what's going on I'm
gonna go check it out and finds Tima is
like what is this who the [ __ ] did this
100 sure they try to break down pieces
of tiama and they were like it's not
working trying to cut it they're like no
one's coming in the water to check it
out maybe we don't yeah I guess how far
is Tiamat again where is he at so Tim
it's like in the South Pacific area why
am I even asking I don't know geography
it's kind of like the opposite place of
where we don't how far are they from the
Atlantic well it's almost like the other
it's not the other side of the world but
they're pretty far away right but it's
like his head could be over here was
yeah toe is over there yes but seeing
how big his head and hands are I don't
think his legs are long enough to go
through the other side of the earth
still an infant he's still in if he was
still growing I don't know
I I I don't know if his foot is like
sticking into Telecom we don't really
know what's helicopter she goes in in
the Yucatan and then goes through like
the jet stream and we don't know where
she wants one of the tall building in
the middle of
toloken is the foot he turns the foot
into the place where the sun happens
testicle you know what I say
um when life gives you lemons make
lemonade that's what you said so when a
God gives you tea turn it into a home
turn into a little bit I just I just
hope there wasn't like a satellite
talocon in the South Pacific that got
destroyed I think if there were no more
would have been really pissed have been
like I'm that's it I'm done with the
surface we're flooding it all I think
but I'm sure he saw that happen in the
water and he swam over with his buddies
and they're like what is this and
they're like I don't know and I I bet no
more was like I bet it's those
dumb eternals I bet they're up to some s
that that or he's just like those
surface people keep messing with us
because we are damaging the waters right
uh go to camera two I'm gonna go off
about climate awareness here we go here
we go I have awareness of your climate
have awareness of the climate it's too
hot and I hate it greenhouse gases
petroleum anything else
that was that was the climate second
with uh Justin Clements I I do think
he's he's mad about the eternals
allowing this to happen and this also we
were kind of talking about this in the
office too do we think the US government
knows about the eternals at this point
are they aware of them the robot yeah no
you don't think so he likes the editor
with a hot take that no one asked for as
someone who has worked in emergency
management for a government agency trust
me they know Cersei just found out she
was a robot right so I don't think any
of them knew about being Roblox but
here's the thing right this is an earth
that's had several events you know the
invasion of the Battle of New York
Thanos
they must have like satellites in space
no listen to me listen they got
satellites in space
the events of Eternal start happening
there's the volcano erupting in the
South Pacific someone in the
government's like we should probably
sign a satellite over see what this
eruption's all about and maybe they're
zooming in and they see like because
they want to know is there some powered
individual that's behind that that's got
anything that happens in the world now
they must immediately think who's behind
this someone with powers is doing this
right so they're zooming in and they see
these little like figurines running
around and they're like who are these
people what are they doing and they're
probably like we need to make a mental
note of this I oh yeah they absolutely
make a mental note of that but they
didn't know they existed in like eight
before that no no this was their first
awareness no they only knew it now
because they know about them I also
think it's like yeah this giant thing's
coming out of the water but it stopped
and we saw a woman kind of climbing on
it and then like a few weeks later a
Celestial shows up and takes and takes
her out of the park honestly again and
this is one of my biggest things about
wakana forever where I was like the US
government is useless in these regards
there is like even when you make the
sokovic video chords even when you try
to stop Wanda it was like who what
what's the what are you trying to do you
can't defeat these people it's you need
it the Thunderbolts but I'm like I
genuinely that in uh eternals I was like
yeah you guys can watch from afar but
try to take down Icarus you stupid we
saw what Superman did to people it's
gonna be tough it's gonna be tough well
Jessica there is an instance of the
eternals and no more having a little
interaction in the comics it's actually
pretty recent uh from eternals number 10
back in March 2022 this was a a rebooted
story of the eternals they've been
living on the planet for a long time and
they're kind of realizing what's going
on it was kind of released in
conjunction with the film a little bit
uh some of the ideas of the film uh but
there was a moment when no more and
Cersei spend some time together uh in
Avengers Mountain at this point the
Avengers base is in a mountain that's
actually a dead celestial's body that's
their home base the Eternal show up uh
and Cersei and no more they have some
time together other and a pool of
healing and stimulating Atlantic and
water to have a conversation the Star
Wars what is it the bacter it's kind of
like bacter I mean namora describes it
as like stimulating Waters
it's implied it's implied that they
potentially hook up scenario so not a
fight but they do hook up the thing is
Cersei hooks up a lot of people in the
comics because Cersei was a party girl
and I loved her friends right uh
Gemma Chan uh and Marvel's in my
universe no I mean with a few people
who've been allowed to have sex in the
MCU so
she was one of the first and we
celebrated it with a very slow auction
it's implied that Tony Sergeant Pepper
Potts had sex I don't think they have
one child at least so they at least had
sex once prove it
um Jessica yeah I I hope we get a get
down the more but I I don't know I don't
know you know why I don't think we will
why because I don't think he likes the
surface people oh that's true he don't
like the surface give us a chance give
us some more we're not all about Zach
always ships everybody Zach Huddleston
if you're listening you ship everyone it
doesn't matter where they're from it
could be someone from the DC Universe
and ours and he's still ours this is
Marvel and he'd still shipped them
together I was there was a there is a
quick second in wakanda Forever where I
was like
is he hitting on shirt it did it did
feel like it was like it did feel but he
gave her also I get this she's like the
first one mom's bracelet what
they're about to get I think I think
he's got a drawer full of this he
doesn't he's handed those out yeah he's
like this is my mother's bracelet and I
fell for it you fell for it I felt like
a record oh
how many I mean it worked this to me it
works so like my mom gave me this ring
and I'm like sleeping I always have a
bucket of bracelets by the bed oh my God
so Jessica to answer this big question
for today do you think the Eternal is a
name or ever officially met in the MCU
uh because of what you said I think
especially Druid Druid yeah I think
Druid and the more definitely had a
conversation and they were like you cool
you cool we're cool we're cool this is
my mom's bracelet you want one you want
one of my boss you know what you got to
do to get it
and I'll do it again I'll burn the world
down
well before we burn down the world we
want to remind you to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can check
out our newest latest Obsession shirt
the forever King inspired by black
panther wakanda Forever This limited
edition shirt will not be available for
long so be sure to grab one before it's
gone forever there's also some new rock
stars some new new rockstars merch
available on the site including some uh
uh collectible enamel pins so be sure to
support the channel and check out all
the merch available at new
rockstarsmerch.com we also want to thank
pharity for sponsoring the show today
Verity is all about clothing for life's
best moments whether it's a Friday night
football game the first day of school or
hanging with the family in your backyard
this fall I can't wait to hang with my
family at Thanksgiving fairy makes
clothes that feel good and make you feel
good Verity Fair family brand that
believes in comfort and quality those
are the key things that they believe in
they were founded by twin brothers Alex
and Mike and Verity grew out of their
long time love of the surf and mountains
road trips and Beach bonfires you know
those feelings you know those fun
feelings Jessica do you do fun things
like that I have family you got family
you got bonfires it's great it's
beautiful Verity is passionate about
craftsmanship and sustainability every
piece is designed to be a lifetime
favorite in fact their clothes get even
better with age and if anything happens
along the way Faraday will replace or
fix your clothes for life no matter what
beautiful stuff layer your favorite
pieces for a cozy fall Vibe or make it
even easier with a one and done jumpsuit
they sell things like that my wife loves
some of the clothes they have a fairity
I personally love their best-selling
soft and stretchy Legend sweater shirt I
talk about it all the time Jessica you
you know it you're sick of me talking
about it it's so soft so comfy and now
that it's nice and cool here in Los
Angeles it's like the perfect shirt to
wear because you can roll up the sleeves
if it's sunny out you can roll them down
if it's cool in the evening it's perfect
find a new fall favorite for yourself at
Verity right now pharity is giving all
big question fans an amazing deal listen
to this folks 20 off on every order you
heard me you get a full 20 off on your
order head to faritybrand.com Big cue
and use code big Q at checkout to get
this deal that's all one word big cue
that's fairity code big Q at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com bigq for 20 off
veritybrand.com
that is where you get 20 off
that's a free jingle that's a free
jingle for you folks okay Jessica it's
time for our next segment which we're
calling versus
I was holding for exciting music maybe
they'll be exciting music I think we
should just zoom in on my face when I
made that noise do it again
versus okay
we put some characters together in a
battle against each other to determine
who would come out on top now I don't
know if you saw this news Jessica it
sent shockwaves through the MCU the
entire power hierarchy of the MCU will
never be the same Ryan coogler said in
an interview on marvel.com that no more
is pretty strong okay he said quote he
has no equal in terms of his
capabilities being able to breathe
underwater and breathe at high altitudes
and walk around on land he's incredibly
strong he's as strong as Thor and if
he's around enough water he can be as
strong as the Hulk we saw in the film
why that water was so important for no
more helps him breathe so let's let's
get let's break this down Jessica let's
see if nemour could be either Thor or
the Hulk okay we're gonna start off by
looking at some official stats from
marvel.com if you go to marvel.com you
look up these characters they give you
some stats on a scale from one to seven
one being the lowest seven being the
highest for different categories okay
these are categories are durability
energy fighting skills intelligence
speed and strength okay let's look at
the tail of the tape for our buddy Thor
the God of Thunder okay his durability
they give him a six pretty high energy
six also High fighting skills four okay
lower he doesn't know a lot of different
techniques he's got a hammer he's got an
ax he throws it around you get it
intelligence too they did my boy dirty
okay he's beautiful but he's not that
smart speed they give him a seven and
strength they give him a seven he's
maxed out on speed and strength he's the
God of Thunder pretty strong wouldn't
you agree Jessica depends on his time on
his time yeah if he's in his feelings if
you catch him in his feelings yeah
that's what I think that's wrong about
these Marvel stats is we'll get into it
we'll get into we'll get it these are
just the officials every comic book is
different every writer gives them
different abilities like
these are the official Marvel comic
stats and then we'll tie it into the MCU
okay okay here we go okay okay so
looking at the Hulk durability seven
obviously maxed out there energy five
got some energy gets tired sometimes
fighting skills again a four they match
them up with four there [ __ ] he
doesn't know many techniques Hulk smash
that's it [ __ ] intelligence six they
give them pretty high intelligence you
should be a seven I mean by Hulk I don't
know speed three the [ __ ] he's not
that fast you see him jump in the sky
[ __ ] that's not speed that's jump
that's speed velocity what is velocity
they don't have a velocity what is
velocity strength velocity
strength is the only thing you got a
seven on no he also got a seven on
durability I think there whatever the
[ __ ] terrible okay let's look at no more
okay I I think they do no more a little
dirty here uh on the official stats
durability six pretty strong pretty
strong energy two low energy not my
number low energy guys fighting skills
four so he's he's tied for fighting
skills with these two other guys all
right intelligence too
I think that's frankly rude that's
frankly right that's not MCU no more
that's comic no more I guess speed three
which we all know again we saw his speed
in the movie he's very special I call
dubious behavior on marvel.com okay and
strength six pretty strong pretty strong
okay so in the comics also no more and
Hulk they fought a few times uh no more
often takes the W and I think this is
solely a device of
they people complain about the Hulk
being nerfed in the MCU they Nerf him a
lot in the comics you know what I mean
they'll find a way to like slow him down
because he's in theory unbeatable and
the more you hit him the stronger he
gets but like you gotta find ways to
like beat him and so Nemours able to
like beat him a few times uh especially
when they're fighting in the ocean don't
fight no more in the sea do not go into
the seat that's what already makes him
stronger is that like the world is more
water than it is
he gonna be the weakest person when he
destroys you in any way and what 80 of
it how much is the water to land I think
it's like 75 but I'll I'll take it we'll
go 89 I'll go up
there's there's one one of the times
they fight in the comics like I think
Hulk's kind of brainwashed or something
and the more punches him so hard that
like he turns back into Bruce
NOW Thor and no more have clashed a
couple times in the comics as well and
Thor usually comes out on top on all of
those instances Thor is really strong in
the comics uh and he's very strong in
the MCU as well all right let's talk
about these MCU characters okay let's go
no more versus Hulk MCU style who do you
think wins that fight I'm really stuck
on picking Hulk and the reason I'm stuck
on [ __ ] Hulk is because I'm assuming
we're gonna have Smart Hulk that if it's
okay I'm assuming it's smart Hulk if
it's more hulk yes normal Hulk
absolutely not uh smart Hulk would be
able to be like okay he's gonna hit the
water at this point or he's gonna hit
like me at this point I think he also
would have deduced just like shurin
don't get into the water yeah don't get
into the water and that heat would
probably get rid of him so I think
knowing that and again I don't want to
be this person but that Hulk jump is
massive yeah he would be like he's gonna
jump and then
if it is smart hook I think you get a
little more advanced if it's just pure
rage Hulk no absolutely I think no more
could maybe outsmart you need the smart
quick no more can like that's why I'm
saying he'll be like okay if he's gonna
bounce off his ankles at this point I
think if you do the math of like because
a lot of his trajectory is just zipping
back and forth I think he'll probably be
like okay I know his tell yeah like
because no more is not thinking of it
mathematically he's just like I need to
evade this I think if no more can catch
Hulk in the air too right he saw him the
more grab that helicopter and like swung
it around very a helicopter that was
moving he's able to grab an air without
anything else to like push off of right
he's solely pushing off his own
abilities in the sky so if Hulk does one
of his jumps the more like Zip Zips UPS
catches him it like spins them around
him throws we've seen that happen to
Hulk so many times right gets back up
and goes out again yeah so that's why
I'm like he's just gonna keep doing it
but to your point Jessica the world is
99 water
and throws him into the water somewhere
now we got ourselves a fight like uh
Zach said he has to fight him in like
Scottsdale Arizona but that's the thing
I yeah if he throws him in water 100 but
I think he's gonna deduce just like
shuri and uh rear Williams at like he
will actually get rid of his power in
the comics sometimes like you can
suffocate The Hulk and make him pass out
but another time he's underwater and his
body just like makes oxygen we also saw
him fight pretty well in water and Thor
Ragnarok yeah so yeah he is fighting
finier in the water there so yeah uh I
think it's yeah I think if it's Mart
Hulk if it's any other Hulk absolutely
not if it was scar 100 no like it has to
be smart Hulk like I don't even think a
She-Hulk could do it it has to be it has
to be smart like engineer mathematician
Hulk what about Thor and no more and
then someone Thor now even like all
father powered up Odin Force Thor Thor
is still hot-headed okay he really he
doesn't think before he does a lot of
his actions and that's what we love
about him yeah which would be stupid not
a planner it's not a planner I think
we'd still get what we got in Thor
Ragnarok where it was like we're friends
we're both gods and then he's gonna
smack the [ __ ] out of it and I think
like if you can get soar underwater the
Lightning's I don't know how effective
it is in the water well so your
lightning still takes certain amount of
time to drop and it's no more like if no
more hundreds of feet under the ocean
can your lightning like get down you
would just get diffused on the surface
we saw a vibranium like ship shooting
lasers at him could not touch him yeah
so it's like it couldn't even touch the
people so it's like no that's not gonna
be Stormbreaker doesn't have the same uh
uh enchantment that like mjolnir has
where it pulls him right right well if
like in theory if you threw mjolnir at
no more it would hit him and he'd be
stuck on the ground and like yeah yeah
yeah but like Stormbreaker no more could
catch and be like zooted out of there
that is true if we did have the If he if
he doesn't have millimeter he's he's not
going to be able to take on that's true
I forgot meal there could just literally
but now now love has has Stormbreaker so
I don't know he's got me on the air I'm
gonna leave I'm Gonna Leave No More and
this is strictly on like a fight
fighting perspective where I'm like okay
if you put them both
um in Ragnarok to fight in that Arena
who would come out and I was like I
think it would be no more I think I I
think you know you get tired after yeah
best best out of three I think
Hulk or a Thor comes out on top yeah I
think he learned if you can get him on
land hit him with that lightning just
Spam the lightning spam the Xbox
he's been with those wings I think you
can evade lightning more than you can
evade the hammer no
he's gonna zap him too many times okay
okay two out of three two out of three I
see that you just want to disagree
you're not listening to Sound Logic from
a mathematician when you provide the
Sound Logic I'll listen to it
I am Sound Logic
that was versus folks I hope you enjoyed
it we also want to thank our sponsor
mint Mobile today this holiday season
the best deal in Wireless can only be
found at mint mobile right now when you
switch to Mint mobile and buy any three
month plan you'll get another three
months for free happy holidays folks as
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only MIT mobile
lets you order and activate from home
with esim while saving tons on phone
plans starting at just 15 a month I've
been using mint mobile long before this
holiday deal and I have to say it's the
perfect time to switch several other
members of the new Rockstar staff have
made the switch mint mobile and they
love the savings and service they get
with mint mobile you could be saving a
lot too think about how good that deal
is a three month plan with three months
more for free that's a good deal put
that money toward getting some gifts for
the fam this year Min lobo's best offer
of the year is here for a limited time
by any three month plan and get three
more months for free by going online
only with esim and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings onto you all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mobile plan and switch
easily and effortlessly with esim or if
you need a new device for a limited time
get six months of free service when you
buy a select device and plan switch to
Mint mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month for a limited time buy any three
month Mobile plan and get three more
months free by going to mintmobile.com
bigq that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mitmobile.com Big Q okay Jessica one of
the other new characters introduced to
the MCU was Riri Williams who we will
soon come to Noah's ironheart in her own
Disney plus Series this is the segment
we're going to be calling the full list
where we recommend subcomics you should
check out if you want to learn more
about a character so if you want to read
more about ironheart before series comes
out or you liked what you did in the
movie you want to see more of it check
out some of these runs okay first we're
going to recommend Invincible Iron Man
number nine from 2015. that was riri's
introduction uh to the Marvel Comics
this was during the Civil War II run
that was happening in the comics at the
time uh so check that one out you could
also check out uh her own comic started
after that it was still called
Invincible Iron Man uh but issues number
one through five from 2016. that's a
great little run there and then you can
also check out the story after that
issues 6 through 11 that was the choices
Arc people really enjoyed that Arc a lot
we recommend that one and also check out
champions from 2019 starting with number
one it was a reboot of the champion
storyline uh but she shows up in there
with a lot of other uh New Avengers
characters Young Avengers characters we
call them Young Avengers younger
Avengers young people young people uh so
check out that comic run if you want to
learn more about ironheart but we
recommend all those check them out it's
good stuff all right Jessica it's time
for from the hive mind this is where we
respond to the masses you folks have
submitted your questions via Twitter
Discord Instagram and just general
screaming into the void and we're here
to answer them our first question today
Jessica comes from mthd on Discord or
maybe method or maybe meft I think it's
method meth on Discord and they asked
what happened to Neymar's people during
the snap
what do you think happened they got
snapped they got snapped I think that's
what happens people are asking not to be
rude not to be rude at all not to be
rude at all people keep asking this
question
and uh what was the one rule I guess of
the snap is it's everybody it's half of
everything so like I think they were
swimming around and they just they're
trading uh coral and and kelp down there
and telecon the papayas the little
papaya see papayas they're trading
awesome
because they just appear back in the
water whereas
children or babies that were just born
get dropped no the drugs everyone came
back safe everyone came back do you
think no more was snapped the classic
question was no more snapped no no and I
think that's why he kept his title being
like the king of the I think I I the
king of the water
[Applause]
are still with him because they were the
only two that were kind of a maybe it
was like their parents or their friends
that like were on his side they got
snapped and they went okay well we'll
step up if you need and he's like okay
let's go I think I think yeah they they
were like uh I'm sure much like we've
talked about like other planets in the
universe who had no idea what was going
on one day half the people disappeared
five years later they all come back and
they're like we don't know what that was
uh who knows what that was I think
they're the perfect uh example of people
that were definitely like yeah okay well
we're back now so I guess just keep
going well I think it happened right and
no more was like what what's going on
what happened to my people he goes up to
the surface he's like oh it happened
here too cool cool everyone's cool you
know they talk about an end game right
there's that moment where you know uh
Steve Rogers is at that kind of group
meeting and they talk about whales being
in the Hudson again do you think that
was like no more swimming up checking
out what's going on yeah we're just like
you
know fish like to check things out
a whale is not a fish
you know it's a mammal they were all in
our backyards in Washington state to the
perfect State yeah they would just swim
up sometimes in your backyard well you
had to live on the water oh I would hope
so all right everybody lived on the
water
they walk they walk and I go oh they're
back get the goddamn guns I'm gonna say
there was also the moment right in the
game where they talk about the
earthquakes underwater you know
wow I'm still attached to that being
them and I don't care they're just like
there's nothing I'm like no you're gonna
and also the thing is the reason why I'm
stuck on it is because Ryan coogler if
you're ever like
yeah actually no let's talk about it
like you can do it go back to it he
doesn't want to talk about it now he's
like I I do think the whales being in
the Hudson what that that was no more
it probably was but I'm sure it was like
maybe they were like hey let's go take
over New York City they're devastated no
the the telekinetic let's go get rid of
it
girl it's happening to the service
people too so that's cool that's cool as
long as you said service people
I did not I did not say that all right
Jessica it's time for everyone's
favorite part
a big question
the box of scraps box of scraps the box
of scraps
of scraps you know ReRe Williams was in
a cave for a little bit and should have
built something with a box of scraps uh
a very Advanced cave right right and
technically maybe whatever she brought
they called the boxes
that would be so rude that would really
complete the Iron Man comparison if Riri
Williams was in there building something
you know he was like kidnapped in a
hostage you know but like Ruby she had a
pretty nice little that was a nice cave
still cave nonetheless still okay but
very nice access to water beautiful
stuff okay Jessica here's today's box of
scraps question no more is one of the
bigger players in Marvel Comics you know
what I'm talking about no he's a player
keep going oh Playa yeah he's a player I
know I fell for the trick I fell for the
bracelet so if you had to choose a
member of the MCU for your next date who
would you choose if you had to pick
anyone in the MCU
you can't have Thanos yeah let's take
out Jonathan Majors entirely because
it's just Jonathan Majors you know it's
just you can date a villain if you want
but I won't let you have Thanos I'm
probably going to date a villain yeah I
know I know
I mean you should date King no we should
be he would be annoying oh my God he
would be the worst he would be genuinely
as like a partner he's been like the
most annoying you go out to dinner he'd
been like I've been to a thousand yeah
Cheesecake Factories across Millennia
I'm tired of these buffaloes I'd be like
you're sleeping with someone else and
you'd be like which version of which
version of me are you back are you
talking about and I'd be like there's
been many versions of me I banged myself
I've banged myself and then try to sound
very deep about it I'm like if you break
up with me you're not gonna like the
other versions of me that send you text
messages
um there was a version in the comic
books of oh my God I think it was it
wasn't doctor strange but it was someone
that was going across the universes in
different timelines and killing
ex-girlfriend in every reality this is a
Marvel comic book look I think white
Vision it's white Visions run
um where they straight up he's like this
girl broke up with me in this time and
I'm gonna go to Every universe and kill
her oh my gosh this was a Marvel comic
book there's a lot of heavy comic books
out there I think genuinely which is not
good at all and I'm very disappointed in
myself saying this out loud I would
choose the hood the hood okay I haven't
seen him yet but uh based off of solely
the comic books where he's a horrible
person but I genuinely am like I think
he'd be a good man to me he had a
girlfriend that he cheated on a lot
um but he he robbed things to like help
his mom yeah and his girlfriend
sometimes
sometimes
sometimes well that's a good answer I
like that one I'll let you to date the
hood uh I'll allow it I don't know why
I'd get permission on this thank you
thanks if if I if I had to choose and
this is a situation where I'm not
married to my beautiful wife who I still
love very much uh but if heaven forbid
she was gone and I had to date someone
from the MCU uh I think I would have to
go with like She-Hulk I mean that's a
good oh I didn't go with the option
she's got a successful job I can kick it
back she can take care a lot of the work
around the house
I didn't say he didn't have a successful
he's got a hard life at the beginning
I I think I would go with Chicago I
think she'd be great to go on well maybe
a day with I want someone I can fix so
you need a broken person I think the
Hood's a little broken yeah maybe I can
help you can fix him I can't fix your
hooks you can fix me if she can fix me
she can fix me like hey baby anytime you
want you didn't even choose you know who
you should have chose oh Nakia Nakia oh
Nikia would be good he's got a I mean
she's got a kid I know and she's gonna
dip out on you real quick yeah yeah
she's gonna well for a good reason
that's the same reason I gotta go do
stuff and I'll be like yeah that's fine
yeah if you're dating like an Avenger
leave but love to watch her go love to
watch her go
yeah she-hulk's not an official Avenger
guy so she's not she's just going to
court she's not dealing with like
fighting bad guys I would just like to
party was she the one problem with
dating She-Hulk is you'll be dating her
and every now and then she'll like turn
somewhere and talk to someone who's not
there and you're like don't break the
fourth wall already
break my fourth wall just break my back
blow my spine out pull it out that's
enough
oh I just
want
I don't want no more I'll tell you that
much okay you guys that's it for the
this week's episode of big question on
our little set yeah we're back baby
we're back and look at it let us know if
we should get more things you just have
to send it to me either way you can
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons and
you can follow Brandon here at grin and
Barrick and be sure to follow new rock
stars on all the platforms you too can
submit questions for big question on our
Discord or by sending it to us on our
Twitter and I think our Discord handle
it's in the description if down below
it's down below baby not in the ocean
but down here check out our merch at
near rockstarsmerch.com and thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week bye
look at my house
[Music]
thank you
[Music]